hello grammarians today I'd like to  introduce you to the verb which is  another part of speech but I suppose the  most fruitful place for us to begin is  by asking what is a verb verb is a part  of speech that has a bunch of different  functions but one of its most important  functions is that it can express or show  action verbs can show action in order to  demonstrate this I have brought along a  little cartoon bear and I'm going to use  this bear in several sentences each of  which will contain a verb because all  sentences contain verbs so I'm going to  write a couple of sentences about the  bear and every time I use a verb I'm  going to write it in yellow like that  here we go  the bear roars the bear runs  the bear sleeps now each one of these  words in yellow is a verb each one of  them is an action and this is the first  thing that verbs can do verbs can show  action in sentences and in fact all  sentences must contain verbs you can  learn anything Dave it out